foreign
[Music]
the origin story around Rocket Raccoon
is a crucial part of Guardians of the
Galaxy 3. time and time again we get to
see flashbacks of Rocket during his time
with the high evolutionary and how he
went from being a little raccoon to the
guardian we know today back then he had
three friends who were created from
batch 89 the same group of experiments
as he was the otter lady Lilla the
rabbit floor and the walrus thieves
rocket raccoon's childhood friends are
not only extremely important to his
story arc in the film the characters can
also be traced back to the Marvel Comics
the scenes of the four Pals made a
lasting impression and brought tears to
the eyes of countless moviegoers that's
reason enough for us to take an in-depth
look at their story
let's begin with Rocket's most
significant childhood friend the otter
lady Lilla in the movie The High
evolutionary gave her mechanical arms
while in the comics she still has her
normal appearance she made her debut in
1982 in the comic The Incredible Hulk
number 271 where she was already closely
related to Rocket she is the heiress of
an Intergalactic toy company called
Mayhem mechanics on half World half
world is a planet where intelligent
animals like Lila care for the sick
until robots develop their own thoughts
and feelings and like the high
evolutionary attempt to evolve the
inhabitants into a superior race through
experiments the half-human half animal
hybrid Judson Jake's trying to take over
Lila's toy company causing the death of
her parents this brought rocket on the
scene who helped Lila defeat jigs the
two fell in love and Lila joined rocket
on his Space Adventures from then on
sadly rocket had to learn that she was
already married to someone who also
inspired her character in Guardians of
the Galaxy 3.
the character in question is floor the
no longer sweet looking rabbit while
Lila is the only one of Rocket's friends
who has a direct counterpart in the
comics director and screenwriter James
Gunn apparently Drew inspiration for
floor and thieves from two other
characters rocket encounters during his
space adventures in the comics floor is
probably Blackjack O'Hare who serves as
a mercenary and is the leader of the
Black Bunny Brigade in the film Thor has
mechanical spider legs and a sort of
muzzle that generates its voice O'Hare
also has modified limbs in the comics
but instead of a new mechanical mouth he
has enhanced eyes which makes him even
more dangerous on the battlefield
although Lila is at first married to
O'Hare she breaks up with him later in
the comics the rabbit mercenaries were
also crucial in Rocket's ability to save
Lila and her toy making company as they
assist our raccoon in his battle after
rocket discovered that he and Lilla were
married they parted ways and Rocket went
back to traveling the Galaxy on his own
the trio is completed by thieves the
walrus in the movie he seems a bit slow
and as if he was not the brightest
modified he sits on a mechanical
wheelchair his name comes from the fact
that he has the biggest teeth of the
three animals his comic book Origins go
back to walrus Lula's uncle and one of
Rocket's most loyal comrades in arms
while Ross and Rocket have a long
history dating back to the war for
control of Lila's toy company who better
to help a stranded raccoon in the
vastness of space than a devoted
engineer like walrus over the years he's
repeatedly saved rocket from dicey
situations including an epic battle
against Blackjack O'Hare and the Black
Bunny Brigade a special feature are his
modified tusks with which he can even
shoot
as you can see Rocket's animal friends
have an extensive backstory how did you
like the three characters in Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 and would you love to
see more of them feel free to let us
know your impressions in the comments
[Music]